we're first exposed to the idea of a
slope of a line
early on in our algebra careers but i
figure it never hurts to review it a bit
so let me draw some axes that is my
y-axis
or maybe i should call it my f of x-axis
y is equal to f of x and let me draw my
x-axis just like that
that is my x-axis and let me draw a line
so let me draw a line like this
and what we want to do is remind
ourselves how do we find the slope
how do we find the slope of that line
and what we do is we take two points on
the line
we take two points on the line so let's
say we take this point
right here let's say that that is the
point x is equal to a and then what
would this be this would be the point
f of a
where the function is going to be some
line we could write f of x
is going to be equal to m x
plus b we don't know what m and b are
but this is all a little bit of review
so this is a this is and then the y
value is what happens to the function
when you evaluated it at a so that's
that point right there and then we could
take another point on this line let's
say we take the point b right there and
then this coordinate up here is going to
be the point
b
b f of b
right because this is just the point
when you evaluate the function at b you
put b in here you're going to get that
point right there so let me just draw a
little line right there
so that is
f of b right there actually let me make
it clear that this coordinate right here
is the point a
f of a
so how do we find the slope between
these two points or it more generally of
this entire line because a line has the
whole the slope is consistent the whole
way through it
and we know that once we find the slope
that's actually going to be the value of
this f that's all a review of your
algebra but how do we do it
well a couple of ways to think about it
slope
is equal to rise
over run
that you might have seen that when you
first learn algebra or another way of
writing it it's change
in y
over
change in x so let's figure out what the
change in y over the change in x is for
this particular case
so the change in y is equal to what well
let's just take you can you can take
this guy as being the first point or
that guy being the first point but let's
take says this guy has a larger x and a
larger y let's start with him so the
change in y between that guy and that
guy is this distance right here so let
me draw a little triangle
that distance right there is a change in
y or i could just transfer it to the y
axis this is the change in y
that is your change in y that distance
so what is that distance it's f of b
minus f of a
so it equals
f of b
minus
f of a
f of b minus f of a that is your change
in y
right here that's your change in y now
what is your change in x so we have the
slope is change in y over change
over change in x well what's our change
in x what's this distance remember we're
taking this to be the first point so we
took its y minus the other points y so
to be consistent we're going to take
this point x minus this point's x so
this point x coordinate is b
so it's going to be
b
minus a
b minus a and just like that if you knew
the equation of this line or if you had
if you had the coordinates of these two
points you would just plug them in right
here and you would get your slope
you would get your slope that
straightforward and that comes straight
out of your algebra one class and let me
just you know just to make sure it's
concrete for you if this was if if this
was the point
let's say this was the point
two
three
and let's say that this up here
was the point
five
seven then if we wanted to find the
slope of this line we would do 7 minus 3
so 7 minus 3 that would be our change in
y this would be 7 and this would be 3
and then we would do that over 5 minus 2
5 minus 2 because this would be a 5 and
this would be a 2 and so this would be
your change in x 5 minus 2 so 7 minus 3
is 4
and 5 minus 2 is 3. so your slope would
be
your slope would be 4
over 3.
now let's see if we can generalize this
and this is what the the new concept
that we're going to be learning as we
delve into calculus let's see if we can
generalize this somehow to a curve so
let's say i have a curve
we have to have a curve before we can
generalize it to a curve let me scroll
down a little bit actually i want to
leave this up here so show you the
similarity so let's say i have
i'll keep it pretty general right now
let's say i have a curve i'll make it a
familiar looking curve
let's say it's the curve y is equal to x
squared which looks something like that
looks something like that
and i want to find
the slope let's say i want to find the
slope
at some point and actually before even
talking about it let's even think about
what it means to find the slope of a
curve here the slope was the same the
whole time right but on a curve your
slope is changing and just to get an
intuition for what that means is what's
the slope over here your slope over here
is the slope of the tangent line the
line just barely touches it that's the
slope over there it's a negative slope
then over here your slope is still
negative but it's a little bit less
negative
it goes like that i don't know if i did
that drew that let me do it in a
different color
let me do it in purple
so over here your slope is slightly less
negative it's a slightly less downward
sloping line and then when you go over
here
at the zero point right here your slope
is pretty much flat because it's the
horizontal line y equals zero is tangent
to this curve and then as you go to more
positive x's then your slope starts
increasing
your slope starts increasing i'm trying
to draw a tangent line and here it's
increasing even more
it's increased even more so your slope
is changing the entire time and this is
kind of the big change that happens when
you go from a line to a curve a line
your slope is the same the entire time
you take any two points in the line take
the the change in y over the change in x
and you get the slope for the entire
line but as you can see already it's
going to be a little bit more nuanced
when we do it for a curve because it
depends what point we're talking about
we can't just say what is the slope for
this curve the slope is different at
every point along the curve it changes
if we go up here just it's going to be
even steeper it's going to look
something like that
so let's try let's try a bit of an
experiment
and i know how this experiment turns out
so it won't be too much of a risk let me
draw better than that so that is my
y-axis
that is my y-axis and
that's my x-axis x and let's call this
we could call this y or we could call
this the f of x-axis either way
and let me draw
my curve again
so i'll just draw it in the positive
coordinate like that
that's my curve
and what if i want to find the slope at
what if i want to find the slope right
there what can i do
well based on our definition of a slope
we need two points to find a slope right
here i don't know how to find the slope
with just one point so let's just say
let's just call this one
let's just call this point right here
let's call that
well that's going to be x we're going to
be general this is going to be our point
x but to find our slope according to our
traditional algebra 1 definition of
slope we need two points so let's get
another point in here
let's get another point in here let's
call let's just take a slightly larger
version of this x
so let's say we want to take this let's
take we hit let's say we have that point
right there actually let me do it even
further out just because it's going to
get messy otherwise
so let's say we have this point right
here and the diff it's just h bigger
than x or actually instead of saying h
bigger let's just let me just say h
bigger so this is x
plus
h that's what that point is right there
so what are they going to be their
corresponding y coordinates on the curve
well this is the curve of y is equal to
f of x
so this point right here
is going to be f of
f of our particular x right here and
maybe to show you that i'm taking a
particular x maybe i'll do a little zero
here this is x naught this is x naught
plus h this is
f of x naught
and then what was
what is this going to be up here this
point up here
that point up here
its y coordinate is going to be
f of
f of this x coordinate which i shifted
over a little bit it's right there f of
this x coordinate which is f of x naught
plus h that's its y coordinate so what
is the slope
going to be between these two points
that are relatively close to each other
remember this isn't going to be the
slope just at this point this is the
slope of the line between these two
points
and if i were to actually draw it out
it would actually be a secant line
between to the curve so to intersect the
curve twice once at this point and once
at this point you can't see it if i drew
if i blew it up a little bit it would
look something like this
it would look something like this
it would look like that where this is
our coordinate x naught
f of x naught
and up here is our coordinate
is our coordinate for this point which
would be the x coordinate would be x
naught plus h
and the y coordinate would be f of
x naught plus h just whatever this
function is we're evaluating it at this
x coordinate that's what it is so these
are the two points so maybe a good start
is just say hey what is the slope of the
secant line
and just like we did in the previous
example you find the change in x
this is sorry the change in y that'll be
your change in y and you divide that by
your change in x
you divide that by your change in x let
me draw it here your change in y would
be that right here
change in y and then your change in x
would be that right there
so what is the slope going to be of the
secant line
the slope
is going to be equal to
let's start with this point up here just
because it seems to be larger so it's we
want to change in y so this value right
here this y value is f of x not plus h i
just evaluated this guy up here it looks
like a fancy term but all it means is
look the slightly larger x evaluate its
y coordinate where it hit where the
curve is at that at that value of x
so that is going to be
so the change in y is going to be f of x
naught
plus h that's just the y coordinate up
here
minus this y coordinate over here so
minus f of
x naught and that's our change in so
that equals our change in y
and you want to divide that by your
change in x
you want to divide that by your change
in x so what is this this is the larger
x value we started with this coordinate
so we start with its x coordinate so
it's x naught plus h x naught plus h
minus
this x coordinate well we just picked a
general number it's x naught
x naught so that is the over your change
in x just like that so this is the slope
of the secant line we still have an
answer what the slope is right at that
point
right at that point but maybe this will
help us get there so if we simplify this
so let me write it down like this
the slope
of the
let me write that properly the slope of
the secant line
is equal to
the value of the function at this point
f of x naught plus h
minus the value of the function here
minus f of x naught so that just tells
us the change in y it's the exact same
definition of slope we've always used
over the change in x and we can simplify
this we have x naught plus h minus x
naught so x naught minus x not cancel
out so you have that over h
so this is equal to our change in y
over change in x fair enough but i
started off saying i want to find the
slope of the line at that point at this
point right here this is the zoomed out
version of it so what can i do
well i defined this second point here is
just the first point plus some h
plus some h and we have something in our
tool kit called a limit this h is just a
general number right this h is just you
know it could be 10 it could be 2 it
could be 0.02 it could be 1 times 10 to
the negative 100 it can be an
arbitrarily small number
so what happens what would happen at
least just theoretically if i were to
take the limit as h approaches zero so
if you know first maybe h is this fairly
large number over here and then if i
take h a little bit smaller then i'd be
finding the slope of this secant line if
i took h to be even a little bit smaller
i'd be finding the slope of that secant
line if h is a little smaller i'd be
finding the slope of that line so as h
approaches 0 i'll be getting closer and
closer to finding the slope of the line
right aft right at my point in question
right at my point of question obviously
if h is a large number my secant line is
going to be way off from the slope at
exactly that point right there but if h
is
.00001 if it's an infinitesimally small
number then i'm going to get pretty
close so what happens
what happens if i take the limit as h
approaches 0 of this
so the limit
as h approaches 0
of my secant slope of let me switch to
green
f of x naught plus h
minus f of x naught that was my change
in y
over
my change in
h which is my change in x
and now just to clarify something and
sometimes you'll see it in different
calculus books sometimes instead of an h
they'll write a delta x here where this
second point would have been defined as
x naught plus delta x and then this
would have simplified to just delta x
over there and we'd be taking the limit
as delta x approaches zero the exact
same thing h delta x doesn't matter
we're taking h is the difference between
one x point and then the higher x point
and then we're gonna take the limit as
that approaches zero we could have
called that delta x just as easily but i
am going to call this
i'm going to call this thing
which equals
which we're saying it equals the slope
of the tangent line and it does equal
the slope of the tangent line i'm going
to call this the derivative
of f
let me write that down the derivative
derivative of f and i'm going to say
that this is equal to
f
prime
of x
and this is going to be another function
because remember the slope changes at
every x value no matter what x value you
pick the slope is going to be different
it doesn't have to be but the way i drew
this curve it is different it can be
different so now you give me an x value
in here i'll apply this formula over
here and then i can tell you the slope
at that point now it all seems very
confusing and maybe abstract at this
point in the next video i'll actually do
an example of calculating a slope and
it'll make it everything a little bit
more concrete